welcome back everyone to round three
recap of the gibraltar battle of the
sexist tournament
in this game i'm playing against grand
master nino basiashvili from georgia
this is the strongest player i've played
in recent memory
although i haven't played too much in
recent memory so i guess that's an easy
thing to say
um coming into this game
i knew she was going to play d4 at least
that's what i was most expecting
and i'll admit i didn't really do so
much preparation
because she has a very broad repertoire
within d4
she can play catalon she can go into
nimzo lines she can play knight f3
earlier
um so i really wasn't entirely sure what
to expect
and
before the game i just tried to clear my
mind again
the rights for the mindset to expect
anything
and we ended up going into
this position
and here i took my first kind of small
think of the game i spent maybe a minute
maybe 90 seconds here
deciding whether to play
d5 or bishop b4
this is probably something i should have
decided before the game
but
both
options had their pros and cons
with d5 this is more of my wheelhouse
comfort zone
um way more solid
the drawback of this though is
i have so many games online uh with pawn
d5 and
i i thought that maybe she was mostly
preparing against this
uh nimzo on the other hand it's a bit
more dynamic
there's more room to play for
exciting positions
and i thought maybe she would be a bit
less prepared for it
given that i don't play the nimzo too
often
at least online and
recent memory i've been playing a lot of
just queen's gamut declined
so we went into nimzo and she proceeded
to blitz out her next about seven moves
um so she was clearly prepared for
what uh what i was playing
uh starting with my f3
i played b6 e3 bishop b7 bishop d3
castling and castling and this is a line
i've played in the past
where the idea
for black actually there's a few ideas
um but the idea that i go for is pawn d5
and i get some sort of like hybrid of
queen's game declined
nimzo indian and queens indian
um just with the pawn structure and the
placement of the bishops
and it's a very strategic line which
from my experience offers black
interesting kind of dynamic play
at the same time white has ways to deal
with this as we're gonna see
she took on d5 i took and she played
knight to e5
which i believe is considered the main
line these days
and
i'll admit it's not a line i was super
prepared for
i was hoping for a more kind of
positional move like bishop d2
after which i could play knight d7 and
get a setup with eventual bishop d6 a6
rookie 8 queen e7
knight e4 etc etc etc
and uh this is actually a pleasant metal
game for black to play but we didn't go
into that and the point of 95 for white
is to get a stonewall setup with f4
and i was aware of this idea and knew
that black should usually try and
pressure the center in various ways
i started with knight bd7 and after f4 i
played c5
and c5 is almost always called for when
especially when white plays pawn f4
and here she played queen to f3
which
was a little bit unsettling and i'll
admit i was a little bit terrified
in this position because white's attack
can come very very quickly
if i'm not careful
uh now first of all the queen line f3 of
course it has ideas of queen h3
but it also aligns with
my my bishop on b7
and i can't play
pawn c4 which is sometimes the move
black wants to play
because very simply bishop takes c4 and
my pawn in d5 is pinned to my bishop i
would just be losing a pawn here
so i didn't play c4 i decided to play
rook to e8
and then she played queen to h3
and i was beginning to feel
under pressure
very early on
not only is h7 a target
but also mine d7 is attacked twice
and my nylon f6 is currently overworked
it's defending both h7 and d7
and if i'm not careful here and i waste
a little bit of time let's say i play a
move like rook c8
looks natural
but this would blunder due to
actually there's a few ways for white to
win material but knight takes e7 i think
is simple enough and if i take with the
knights i lose h7
if i take with a queen okay here there's
bishop f5 but there's also bishop takes
h7 and i can't take because then i would
lose the queen
so i'd be very careful of
tactical ideas for white
and i decided to play knight to f8
which was one of the reasons why i put
the rook on e8 is to free the f8 square
for either the knight or my bishop in
this case the knight
and this over defends
h7
it also uh removes the knight from d7 so
there's less to worry about with uh
knight being exposed
uh the drawback of this move is it does
expose this diagonal
which she uh
she tried to take advantage of with the
move bishop to b5
and when she played this move
i became even more terrified
because bishop b5 is a type of move that
white plays if there's something very
concrete in the position
first of all the rook's attacked i don't
want to put a knight back on d7 and walk
into a pin
i played rook e7 which is only a logical
move here
and
black does have to worry about the
potential for the knights or the bishop
coming into c6
and i was taking a lot of time in the
opening trying to ensure that
everything's under control which it
turns out to be the position is under
control
i don't think it's any good for white to
invade
by putting a minor piece on c6
for example if bishop c6
there's not really a threat for white
i could play a move like queen c8 offer
queen trade and after takes takes my
rook defends the bishop takes takes
white's getting nothing here
there is another line
which was maybe a bit more interesting
knight c6
forking and after takes takes
there is a calculation if i play rook c8
i might have to worry about bishop takes
d5
because after takes takes
i can't take back because then i lose a
rook
so
i figured that the worst case scenario
if we entered this position
i would just put the rook on b8
and there's no more tactics involving uh
bishop takes d5
and
i think this is fine for black even
though i've conceded the bishop pair
this bishop's on c6 kind of in no man's
land and uh position would still be very
playable
so after rookie seven she played bishop
d2
and then i was feeling a bit more less
terrified because then i was able to
gain time against white's light square
bishop after e6 bishop a4 b5
i'm expanding with tempo
bishop c2
now this bishop has moved one two three
times
just to find itself on the same diagonal
it was originally at
and
i'm i'm making progress gaining space on
queenside
and here i decided to play rook 2 c8
now i will admit uh in this position i
took a really long think
because there's so many different ideas
for black to choose from
uh i consider taking on d4 consider
queen b6
96 even bishop takes c3 with some b4
ideas
uh there's just a lot of candidate moves
and i wasn't entirely sure how to
even approach a thought process in this
position
and when i played rook c8 it wasn't
really based on so much calculation it
was just based more on
intuition
i knew that
my rook is one of my worst place pieces
might as well put it on a file that's
very likely to open up and then just
maintain all the tension in the position
between the pawns and
with the bishops as well
so here she played bishop to e1
and again i had a decision to make
and i play the move which maybe it looks
a bit counter-intuitive at first as
bishop takes c3
uh normally
i don't want to just take the knight
when it's not called for
at the very least black should wait for
a3 before taking the knights
but i took on c3 because it's a very
concrete line
white can't take back with the bishop
because of issues on the c file after c
takes d4 i believe black is winning
material here uh pawneex d4 and then b4
and i'll be winning
at least two minor pieces for rook with
just a much better position
so
she had to take back with pawn
and
now the drawback for white is after
takes takes
white's left with this very
weak backwards pawn on c3
it's on a half open file
and on top of that i get in 94
and the position just becomes really
pleasant from here
because a very powerful knight targeting
the pawn f6 is coming very soon to
remove white's best piece from the
center
and meanwhile white's pieces are lacking
a bit of harmony and coordination
especially with this bishop on e1
now i will note that if bishop h4 i
would happily play f6
and target the knight and then
c3 would consequently be uh be very
vulnerable i think white would be losing
material here
knight and the pawn are attacked
so she decided to play rook d1 here i
continued with my game plan played pawn
f6
force knight back to g4
i will note here if the knight moves to
d3 or f3
it would obstruct the queen from
defending c3
and
then i would happily just stack the pawn
so
knight g4 was played
and here i continue with queen c7
just putting more pressure on the c3
pawn
she played rook 2 c1 which was a nifty
move the idea was to defend the pawn
with tactics because if i take
uh very temporarily go up the pawn but
after takes takes there's bishop takes
h7 with check
and then oh no my queen
so
of course i was aware of that and here i
decided to play just a very simple
prophylactic move
king to h8
just getting out the way of the
potential bishop checks
also i thought my king is just safer on
h8 given that the knight can't
potentially check it
so it just reduces the amount of
tactical possibilities that white has
and now there might actually be a threat
of taking because if i take on c3
there's 92 ideas and then white wouldn't
have time to exploit the
x-ray vision against my queen so for
this reason she went ahead and defended
the pawn with bishop to b3
unleashing the rook
so now we have three attackers
and three defenders
so i still can't win the pawn but
i'm still looking to
improve the position so one of the
strategies for black in this position is
to continually improve as many things as
possible
and try and build up as much pressure as
possible against white's position
and that led me to playing pawn a5
which is a multi-purpose move
potentially preparing pawn b4 with a pin
along the c file
also some ideas of pawn to a4 to hit the
bishop
and thirdly there is ideas of bishop a6
to get the bishop to a more lively
diagonal
so here she played knight to e3
which is a counter-attack hitting the
pawn on d5
i defend it with rook d8
and now she plays queen to f3 so it was
very clear that white's pieces are just
lacking harmony
um bishop is still on e1
the
knight and bishop even though they're
directed the pawn the pawn is well
supported and i realized that this was
my time to strike and i went ahead and
played b4
which
adds another attacker to the c3 pawn
white can't take it because the rook's
not defended on c1 this is one of the
reasons why you should usually try and
connect your rooks in the middle game is
to avoid situations like this where you
would really like your rook to be
defended
so white is under a lot of pressure here
but she found a
interesting move to
to counter-attack is knight f5
hitting my rook and unleashing the queen
to defend the pawn
i simply move back
and here she played rook c2
with a reasonable intention to get the
rook to defend its square
and threatened to take on before it hit
my queen
unfortunately for her
rook c2 is walking into a really nice
tactic for black
and for those of you that haven't
watched the game
i do encourage you to pause the video
and find the tactical opportunity for
black in this position
now i will say that i had seen this
position from back when i played b4 i
thought this was one of the more natural
lines i could play is knight f5 roxy ii
i very quickly spotted the fact that
there's a couple things to exploit
against white's position
there's actually a double attack here
it's to play the move queen
to d7
hitting the undefended knight on f5
and also preparing to trap the bishop
with pawn a4 so i'm using both sides of
the board
to try and win material here
and when i played queen d7 i thought i
was just easily winning there's didn't
seem like there's any way for lights
to hold on to material
but then she played a move queen g4
which does walk into a pin
but it had some interesting
sort of resources behind it
which made me think for a while here
because first of all if i play a4
uh then i actually probably just lose
after bishop takes a4 my queen is tied
down to defending against mate so queen
a4 queen g7
white would win
the move i wanted to play was pawn g6
to exploit the pin
this would force knight h6
and it looks like black is winning after
pawn f5 hitting the queen and there's
still a threat upon a4 but as i kept
calculating here i realize the position
gets a little bit murky because white
can play queen h4
and if i go ahead and trap the bishop
there's bishop takes a4 queen takes a4
and then knight f7 check
i would lose my rook
and if i win this rook i lose my bishop
and i was calculating for a while this
line i can take on c3
and it looks to be
good for black
but i wasn't a hundred percent sure
and my time was getting somewhat low
like it was fell below 15 minutes
and
i took a step back in uh in the position
after queen g4
and just started searching for candidate
moves
and sometimes this is a
a problem
is when i spot an interesting line
i'll just go super deep into that one
line
in this case that line was g6 i was
trying to calculate and make it work
but
i took a step back and looked for
alternatives just other moves that can
possibly work here
and i realize that knight d6
leads to just a simpler position to
understand
and look to be a lot cleaner
the point is i attack the knight which
is pinned to the queen
knight e3 is not possible even though it
defends the queen it will leave the
knight hanging
and um i think the best try for white
here is to play bishop a4
to again exploit the fact that i can't
move my queen away from defending g7
but after queen takes f5
we could get a position like this after
takes takes takes takes
where i would have two minor pieces for
a rook but i would also have initiative
here because i'm threatening knight to
e3 with a fork
also threatening bishop a6 to remove the
rook from defending the bishop so i
calculated this and thought it should be
a pretty straightforward win
but to my surprise she didn't go into
this line
instead she took on d6 with a knight
and for a moment i i was in shock
thinking that is this just a free queen
and i thought for a bit because usually
when you're playing a grand master and
they give you a seemingly free queen
you should think twice before taking it
and then i realized oh she's just
wanting to get a couple minor pieces for
the queen
but thankfully a queen is worth more
than a couple minor pieces
and uh i took the queen
i should point out here that there's
also an if7 but this doesn't hurt me i
just play king g8 after it takes takes
black is up more than enough material so
she did take on b7
i played rook to b8 hitting the knight
knight takes a5
i check on c3 rook takes c3
and now i've played knight to e6
now even though i have a substantial
material advantage i'm trying to be
extra precise with the way i approach
this position
a common pitfall for me and for a lot of
other players too
is that when you get into a winning
position
it's easy to get relaxed and careless
and that's something that i think can
prevent people from converting winning
positions
and i saw that she's really like she was
still really focused really trying to
fight so i was trying to be
as precise as possible with 96 i do hit
both pawns
uh she counter attacked with rook g3
i moved back to f5
and then she played knight to c6
attacking the rook and defending the
pawn
i moved the rook hit the knight
she played bishop to a4
and then i played the move queen to e4
i should note at this point we were both
getting pretty low on time but
she was much lower in time she was
hovering around i think 30 seconds to a
minute just living on increments
we were on move 35 so five more moves
until we get an extra half hour on the
clock so here she played bishop to f2
giving me a pawn i took on f4
and now rook to f3
so avoiding the potential fork because i
was threatening knight to e2 i was
hoping for rook e3 which would then just
allow mates but rook f3 was was the best
try
i played pawn g5
defending the knight making luft for my
king
she played pawn h3
i played rook to a8
hitting the bishop
and after bishop b5
i took on a2
this was my 39th move i played it with
maybe about a minute left
and right after i took on e2 i realized
i overlooked white's next move
she played the move knight to b4
hitting both rooks
and for a brief moment i panicked
thinking oh no i'm losing back material
but then i realized
my pieces are so well placed
both of these things are undefended so i
spotted a pretty simple combination here
i can give up my rook on f2 sack it for
the bishop and after rook takes f2
play the move rook to b8
and here there's no way for white to
hold on to
both of the minor pieces
i'll be winning either the knight or
bishop
and then be up even more material
and after a short think she resigned in
this position
and this marks my first win of the
tournament so individually this puts me
at one and a half out of three
um the men's team today
performed really well with black we had
four wins on the team the rest of the
games were draws
so trying to fight back still behind by
a few points but it is getting closer
and what else to say um i think it's
time for me to
sleep
or maybe prepare
or maybe sleep